ich schaue sehr sehr wenig youtube auf
dieser plattform doch es gibt wirklich
einen kanal ich finde er hat irgendwie
etwas da bin ich wirklich täglich wird
dabei und genau auf ein video von diesem
kanal werden heute reagieren und war
mein queen lorenz oken deutschland
älteste gamer wir reagieren mal wieder
auf einen seniorenforum video wie freund
schon gesagt da gehen wir heute auf
minecraft video von denen es hat schon
fast neun millionen aufrufe wir haben es
endlich getan die senioren tauchen ein
in die welt von minecraft wir haben die
aufgabe erst einmal sehr simpel gehalten
und so schauen sie sich die senioren mit
der welt anfreunden das wichtigste erst
mal wenn man sich ein video von den
senioren trocken anschaut ist erstmal
schön einen daumen nach oben da lassen
könnt ihr übrigens auch bei diesem video
jetzt grad machen also geht nach unten
last lag da und wir schauen ist das
video
wenn ich diese interessen der senioren
focken minecraft h
das heißt es bei allem respekt er will
das hier ist doch ein haar das sieht
doch jeder dass ein m s oder meine kraft
um das ist aber eine gute theorie
eigentlich also mit minen hattet ja was
zu tun weil man muss ja erst abbauen und
alles mögliche und blabla aber meine
kraft hält sich eigentlich auch wenn
also von wegen mai kraft also dass es zu
einem selbst gehörte steht etwas mehr
nicht
ja
wow
die helga schönes match und gerade
erwünscht die helga der band es unter
den senioren
[Musik]
hat was verpasst helga wasser was sie
mit theorien irak haben dieses meine
kraft mäßig also von wegen des geldes
meinen spielen meine kraft ein bisschen
und jetzt kommt die große ja sagt meint
kraft von bingen gedächtnis brennen wir
vielleicht schon sehen hab ich auch für
das heutige video eine andere
perspektive hier gewählt also wenn ich
einfach die standard perspektive
genommen habe die komplette wer meine
fans direkt über dem gewichteten jahren
gewesen deswegen habe ich das
miteinander sie gemacht
das ist in ordnung
deren spiel wir haben den senioren
folgende aufgabe gestellt bis zu sechs
steine aus dem boden ab aus den steinen
zwei säulen drei blöcken jeder zeigen
egal wie das ganze ablaufen würde sie
sollen zwei von solchen säulen bauen und
das ist dann glaube ich auch schon die
aufgabe oder ja genau jetzt geht's los
nur da kannst du kurz wie genau nur da
wieder beteuerte jeweils ankommen meint
ich mach mich über die lustig nein also
ich glaube jeder weiß dass das da sehe
ich ein zwei drei kleine knöpfe
den laufenden dort schon weg bekomme ich
mich deiner musik lockt dahin kann ich
fragen und anfragen ist da und wir uns
was ich anklicken können
drei haben ja erfolgreicher ich hab drei
evelyn
3 das werden zwei blöcke wir schauen mal
[Musik]
also erst
er sagt er will in sie hat drei bürger
wo sie zwei hat und dann sagt sie dabei
habe kann ich einen wieder wegmachen
baut zwei blöcke dahin
[Musik]
ein paar sekunden später eingebaut
nein
helga linksklick abbauen rechtsklick
hinsetzen also ich weiß nicht wie viel
die enkelkinder da denen irgendwie als
tutorial vorhergesagt haben aber ich
schau mal wie sie sich weiter schlagen
er will ihn hier wieder am start
laut dem blog an die helga die bauträger
in gang
[Musik]
ihr wollt zwei säulen bauen ich will
dass damit nehmen
[Musik]
ich muss mich wirklich zurückgehalten
nicht jetzt nach dem video wieder alle
video von denen ich zuschauen allein
diese tatsache der prägung 90
es war meine baukunst luft
ich meine es interessantes ja wie weit
die verschiedenen senioren hier wirklich
sind die villen kamen halt überhaupt
nicht klar die hat irgendwie ihre ganze
blöcke gehabt dann wieder irgendwo hin
gesetzt die heldin die angeblich unter
einer pyramide aber jetzt hier auf jeden
fall die große halle und die eu steht ja
schon relativ city hat auch direkt
begriffen hier mit meinen kräften alles
also schon wieder draußen war ich mich
wieder zurück
doch moment mal wir sind jetzt hier los
was ist denn heute
ich weiß ich kann das so einfach sagen
weil ich ja mein verlangen gespielt habe
aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen so
schwierig ist höchste bauen oder vor
allem sind klar auch heute noch hinter
der kamera und construction
[Musik]
gebt euch einfach mal wie er will auf
diesen ganz normal stinkenden dirt blog
da reagiert genauso jetzt da raus bist
du
[Musik]
sonst tun bauen
sie hatte als standard aufgabe zwei
türme zu bauen das hat sie nicht
beachtet sondern setzt sich unter ihnen
der pyramide geburt an hat die irgendwie
eigenständig wieder rausgekommen ist
dann ins wasser gesprungen unter wasser
am tag dann hat mich schwer im keller
unter wasser ist kein keller unter
wasser unter wasser wie komme ich denn
hier wieder raus ist das meinte ja nicht
anders spielen
[Gelächter]
da ist noch immer er will nur meine
damen und herren um drauf jetzt genau
rechtsklick in wetten
er würde nur den rechtsweg ob hummer
kein eis zeigen die sonst aber man lernt
immer noch dazu braucht er 10 38 jahren
sagt sie findet das spiel sehr gut weil
man muss da keinen abknallen man muss da
keinen jagen naja also ihr habt ja
bisher wirklich als aufgabe gehabt zwei
ärzte zu bauen also in dem spiel gibt's
auch noch anspruchsvollere sache dort
wirklich kein kloster bauen oder oder am
kloster wer hoch begabt ist und es finde
ein bisschen am computer bescheid weiß
für den mag das vielleicht sein also für
mich ist es schwerer als jetzt nachts
schlafen gehen wichtig vorher gemacht
habe
also man merkt wirklich wie die burschen
die ist wirklich gemacht dafür
eigentlich die macht das mega gut finde
ich die kommentiert perfekt die erfasst
hat alles gerade mal ganz zusammen sagt
jetzt ja okay sie hat wirklich gekämpft
wie geht jetzt schlafen die probiert am
nächsten tag nochmal halten keinem wort
verstanden rwe sind das was er heute
wollen wieder meine damen und herren so
viele von euch haben sich mal wieder
gewünscht sich auf ein video von
senioren zog reagiere wenn es euch
gefallen hat das gerne mal ein like das
einfach mega spaß weil der kanal ich
finde die idee haben wir deswegen das
video noch oben in der beschreibung von
links auf jeden fall mal aus den schönen
grüßen aber david findet jetzt hier oben
ein smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
könnte main kanal kostenlos abonnieren
fast keine videos mehr findet auch mein
job eingeblendet und hier unten ist ein
anderes video verlinkt und wenn die
langeweile habt könnt ihr als gerne
auflegen all das bestimmt
[Musik]